good afternoon this is NHS crisis your
say today Sky News is launching a
year-long project with analysis from two
leading think tanks to find solutions to
this crisis that is gripping our
National Health Service and this
afternoon we are taking your calls we
want to hear from you it's a real chance
to share your views about what is
happening to the Health Service and
before we get into your calls plenty of
you lining up to speak to us I just want
to introduce you to Our Guest that will
be with us for the duration of the
afternoon we have Roy Lily with us
policy uh Health policy analyst and
former Vice chairman of West Surrey and
North East Hampshire health authority
alongside Roy this afternoon Dr Ellie
Cannon GP and author welcome to you both
um don't forget the number to call today
if you want to speak to us here in the
studio 0208
1672200 there'll be plenty of reminders
of that number on the screen throughout
the program for you here on Sky News
today right let's hear from you first of
on the line today we have Victoria from
Horsham we're going to be talking in
this section about waiting times in the
Health Service and the experience you
have if you are able to see one if
you're able to get access to treatment
Victoria and West Sussex
um his father died in hospital
um after waiting five months to be
discharged and Victoria thank you so
much for calling in to speak to us here
this afternoon and no talk to me about
what happened to your dad
um initially it was about 7th of August
um I sort of went to his flat and found
him in a bit of a state so I called 999
and they were there literally within
half an hour so you know that was a
great positive
um they looked after him they took him
to hospital and he had some gastric
stomach gastric infection that was
causing him to be quite poorly
um so they kind of gave him antibiotics
and fluids and that was all okay and
then I was told you know your dad can go
home but he was quite frail so he would
need some sort of care package to go
home with
um and that never came and this went on
and on and then he kind of got covered a
couple of times he'd never had it before
he's always been really careful so that
was disappointing
um and then he got over that and again
was ready to go home again and then
again no care package and then just
before New Year's um he got like a
proper flu so he was isolated into a
sort of separate room we could still go
and visit
um we did sort of usual PP and
everything
um and then the flu uh went to his chest
he got a chest infection and sort of the
first week of Jan he developed pneumonia
and he passed away on the sixth of Jan
from pneumonia
oh Victoria first of all I'm so sorry
for your loss
um but just listening to all of that
your father was waiting for five months
yeah to be discharged from hospital we
originally went in with stomach problems
correct and then he he died in hospital
from unrelated Matters from absolutely
yeah from what you've been saying yeah
um talk to me about how that happened
you mentioned a care package and that
wasn't able to be put in place now I
know what a lot of people may say to you
Victoria just of curiosity you know your
father clearly had family had you he may
have had other members of family and why
couldn't he go home what kind of care
did he need and it wasn't being given by
the NHS that that made him stay in
hospital for five months he needed very
sort of intimate Personal Care
um so he'd lost control of his bowel
after having this gastric infection so
he was wearing sort of incontinence part
of like almost like nappies really
um and he also
um had got very frail he was had a lot
of muscle wasted while he was in
hospital
um he was having some kidney problems as
well
um he was kind of waiting to see his
kidney doctor all this time so that were
desperate to get him home so there were
other symptoms he was quite anemic there
was other problems just just things that
you know I know she's got specific
medical training
um it's not something that just a family
member could pick up and and he needed
to sort of care with everything you know
getting up his personal care washing
um where he lived wasn't really suitable
so that was another thing but they
couldn't get him moved somewhere more
suitable until he was home and then he
could be assessed so everything was kind
of pinned on him getting home with the
care package and he then would have been
moved um to a they call it like an extra
care scheme where they have nurses on
site that live there they have walk-in
wet rooms so his bathing would have been
easy he could have done that himself or
where he lived he would have needed help
with pretty much everything
um I worked full-time I've got two
children so unfortunately I wasn't able
to you know give give up work to kind of
give them that care and that's and
there's also you know there's just
things that I'm not medically trained to
do
um so I didn't really feel like I could
have provided that for him so he was
ready to go home you know I think he
must have been about four times I got
the call to say oh Dad can go home but
we need to wait for the care package
because he does need care probably three
times a day with his bathing just before
bed and all sorts of common sort of help
him doing something so that I can done
the lunch time just to give him some
food
um but the other personal care I just
wasn't able to do that yeah no Victoria
it's important to say that because
obviously that is something that said a
lot when people say well why do you need
a care package you a family that could
look after you and you've given us the
bigger picture it is not that simple and
Elliot Roy you were nodding along to
what Victoria was saying there and Roy I
think you whispered to Ellie we hear
this a lot if this is a this is a common
problem it is and and Victoria I'm so
sorry to hear that story but it it
encapsulates really the problems that
we're facing now and the NHS did its bit
as as much as it could and then of
course it can't look after people when
they're in their own homes that's the
difficulty that we've got and so we look
to our Partners in Care which are
organized by Social Services what you
were wanting was a package from
domiciliary care domiciliary care and
the care sector generally
um has about a 160 000 vacancies at the
moment and getting the care packages in
place is super difficult and that means
then of course that that person is in
bed in a hospital for much longer than
need to be something called
deconditioning takes place where there
they get worse it makes you vulnerable
to things like flu exactly and and as
much as they the hospitals try to avoid
that sort of cross-contamination it's
really very very difficult and and at
the heart of this at the heart of most
of the problems that I'm sure we're
going to hear about this afternoon is
the Victoria example where actually what
we need to fix is social care and and
I'm sure Ellie sees that every day in
her practice Yeah in your practice you
must hear that a lot from families who
you know you're a first Port of Call as
a GP then that patient may go into
hospital and you know people always say
it's difficult to get into hospital it's
difficult to get into GDP but actually
it's difficult to get out of Hospital
absolutely right and people talk now
about patient flow so flowing from
primary care with me
through an ambulance through a hospital
now the other side and it's out the
other side as Victoria's described into
social care that is causing such a
problem with people and it's incredibly
upsetting as well from the human point
of view that this was you know the end
of your Dad's life Victoria and I'm so
sorry that that's sort of how everything
played out and as Roy said you know
Hospital itself is not a good place for
people to be it's great when you're
acutely unwell and my Hospital
colleagues sort people out but then to
sit there and not to have family around
and deconditioning as Roy said allows
unfortunately this very sad end of life
situation to play out and what I think
we'll also hear this afternoon as well
is this story could have been different
in another part of the country we have a
postcode Lottery there could have been a
different social care issue somewhere
else there may have had better staff and
actually it's not a homogeneous system
and this didn't have to happen yeah
Victoria thank you so much for speaking
up for
um your family your dad and other
families like you who are going through
the same thing in the National Health
Service Anastasia from Leeds is on the
line now Anastasia has cerebral palsy
and Anastasia you've been on the NHS
waiting list for nearly three years for
treatment that is absolutely correct and
I feel it absolutely infuriates because
I feel like I'm losing the will to live
to Corona phrase
um I I mean as you said I've got
cerebral palsy and for what I'm
concerned about is that I've got this I
will say it because it puts it in
context I have a it's not easy to say
but I have a Urological condition and I
just want it fixed and I'm I'm not
receiving any social care I'm not
receiving any support unfortunately I
come from a care background through no
fault mail because my mother put me in
an institution at the age of two weeks
old and so the support isn't there I
have to fight or always for myself and
in fact
I was once called up for um for the
appointment because I will say that
Botox isn't only for as you know it's
not only for cosmetic reasons and to
have to have this um procedure and um a
second time and they said oh we didn't
realize that you um have several
cerebral palsy so they don't actually
get the their acts together we need to
joined up thinking it varies I've lived
in many areas throughout in different
areas throughout the country it all
often depends on who you speak to and I
don't feel uh listened to when it comes
to social care it depends on whether
somebody has the ability to do this to
do the assessment or not and even if you
do have an assessment then you you don't
necessarily get
um your needs met so you you know I I
don't know what to do and and what
worries me is the fact that the
situation to me and for others can
actually get worse and you know I
believe that my condition is getting
worse and worse and worse
Anastasia I can hear how upset you are I
just want to go to Dr Ellie at this
point because look Anastasia is at her
wit's ends waiting three years for
treatment which will be no doubt
Anastasia correct me if I'm wrong class
as non-urgent I mean you know there are
six million people currently uh waiting
for treatment in the UK Anastasia making
up that number what advice would you
give to Anastasia because she doesn't
feel like she's getting any support it
is urgent I mean I'm not I'm not I'm
sorry I meant I mean by the nhsa because
it was non-urgent but of course it's
urgent to you it's affecting your life
so I would say a couple of things I mean
first of all speak to your GP and make
sure the referral has gone through I
know that sounds ridiculous but we're
all human and we're relying on sort of
Technology as well and sometimes
referrals don't go through so deaf
definitely make sure see what your GP
can do in terms of the referral the
other thing is speak to Pals who are the
patient advisory so advocacy service
within hospitals and see what's
happening with your appointment and see
you know see if you can make sure
because obviously as you've rightly said
you know this isn't just a health
problem that needs fixing there's a
health problem that needs fixing that
then infects your employment your
quality of life what care package you
need and actually if this was sorted out
then you would need probably need less
help from elsewhere yes exactly this is
a system problem uh and you know we we
call them interfaces where one bit of
the service joins up to the next bit and
it's it's like people people trip over
the joint in the paving stones on the
patio they trip over the joins in the
services as well and it's so often that
you get these service interfaces that
let you down yeah okay let's bring in
animal from Birmingham who's on the line
uh who is a big fan of the NHS and is
disappointed that it's got this place
and all tell me what you want to say
today
well basically I feel
the institution itself is absolutely
magnificent we are most countries are
jealous of iron in chess
and the present government for the last
12 years
has not funded enough because it seemed
as if they want to break the system up
and privatize and privatization just
means shareholders make money instead of
the NHS serving the people look what
happened in the USA I was involved in
surgery first in 2008 I had a heart
attack and the treatment I received was
Immaculate the ambulance got to me
within five minutes
okay I had surgery last November and
quite serious surgery I got all my
prostrate
and the nurses literally worked their
guts out
and
to now say to them they they don't
deserve a paywright
it just I just believe that we are the
fifth richest country in the world
and we can't afford to pay our nurses
a salary they can live on
if you're just joining us here on Sky
News we are discussing the state of the
National Health Service NHS crisis it's
your say today we're handling the
program over to you get in touch with us
1672200 whether you work within the NHS
or you've had experience recently using
it good or bad we want to hear from you
we're exploring everything that's going
on in the NHS service at the moment that
was Arnold from Birmingham who is very
complimentary of the NHS and received
great treatment
um let's speak to Tony from Preston and
he is talking about physio appointments
the waiting times are ridiculous Tony
talk to me about why you need one and
how long you've been waiting
well I've been playing sport for over 60
years and since 2003 I've had three new
hips an ankle fused a cartilage out and
tendons done in my shoulder and I've
never waited more than a month to be
seen and never waited for more than
three months for an operation with four
different surge surgeons
I had an accolades injury on the 3rd of
October I'm basically struggling to walk
so I went to my doctor on the 8th of
October and I was off with a physio
appointment on the 14th through the 5th
of December which was over two months
later
I couldn't get a physio appointment at
the local hospital
so I got a physio or a call with a
private physio an appointment for the
4th of December
on the 4th of December they then said
we're canceling your physio appointment
and we can offer you another one on the
17th of February so it took four months
to get a an appointment and I don't know
whether that's going to go ahead in the
meantime I needed a scan on the ankle
so I only got me scan last week which
was the 17th of January three months to
get a scan it's absolutely appalling and
I'm now waiting to see a surgeon so I
rang the Orthopedics at the local
hospital and they told me it could be
two to three months and after that it
would I would get an appointment for a
for an operation in either 12 to 18
months so if I'm lucky I'm going to get
an appointment uh or get something done
in my ankle and it's going to take two
years to do that
feared intimate taxis for 57 years I
need to be active for me on sensanity
and mental health it's doing me no good
at home
um I'm I'm so disappointed with the uh
with the waiting list now it's
absolutely terrible yeah Tony you won't
be on your own in that two years to to
get your ankle sorted like you said it's
your physical health is also your mental
health you want to be mobile right you
can be mobile you're just being made to
wait for two years but it's actually
made you go private hasn't it well I'm
seriously thinking of going private no
it's not only principles
um but I'm struggling to walk and I just
can't put up with this any longer so you
know when you've paid all your taxes you
should be able to get an operation like
I've had for the last well 20 years as I
told you I've had six operations with
the NHS and it's been absolutely superb
service but now I can't even get the
scam can't even get an appointment with
a surgeon and certainly it's going to be
too long for me to get an actual
operation Roy why isn't someone like
Tony prioritize because
you know I suppose you don't want to
compare ailments or you know anything
like that but you know you might look at
an ankle and go well it's not urgent but
again for Tony like Anastasia said for
these people it is urgent it's affecting
their life see it's for everybody it's
an important thing I mean you can't make
a comparability you know between people
and their troubles I mean Ellie I'm sure
we'll talk about an Achilles tendon I
mean it sounds to me like that needs to
be built with more urgently than just
waiting for a scan but the the situation
is this the NHS is like a a big
production line you know sick and poorly
people go in one end and hopefully happy
and fixed up people come out the other
and it doesn't take much to disrupt that
production line and that's what's
Happening Here the production line is
bunged up because we've got people in
hospital that we can't get home we don't
have enough staff on the wards with the
NHS is still struggling with covid I
mean most of us think Kobe it's over but
it's not for the NHS were in the middle
of a flu season which is one of the most
horrendous flu Seasons I think we've
seen for a long time and of course on
top of that we've got the disruption of
the strikes so when you get that kind of
disruption in the system it has a
knock-on effect so if you take something
like a scan if if the hospital is
preoccupied with scanning people who are
already in hospital who've been admitted
there isn't the capacity and this is a
word we're going to hear a lot this
afternoon the NHS doesn't have the
capacity to deal with the problems and
there's lots of reasons for that and
we'll no doubt talk about them later on
but this is a capacity issue there
should be enough Headroom in the system
to say to outpatients who want to scan
come in but at the moment the capacity
is full really by impatience yeah
absolutely and I'm sure you know about
sort of figures for the number of
physiotherapy jobs that are vacant at
the moment now interestingly we've
mentioned already postcode Lottery this
is not a story that I would recognize as
a patient Journey from my practice
because where I work we have what's
called a community musculoskeletal
service so actually people see
physiotherapists very quickly they at
least speak to them very quickly and
likewise myself referral absolutely and
likewise my patients do not wait three
or four months for a scan on an Achilles
it's actually quite quick yes they might
wait for surgery but the process would
have been started so again this is back
to the fact that we have areas where we
have a really good gold standard of care
but there's no mechanism for other areas
to learn or to copycat those Services
you know Tony like when you listen to
that you're a victim of where you live
in terms of it's a postcode Lottery as
to how long you will wait what care you
will receive and when
oh we lost it Tony still with us yeah
I'm still with you yeah yeah Tony you
know that must be very frustrating to
hear that it's a postcode Lottery
essentially you're a victim of where you
live
yeah I mean it's terrible isn't it when
you think about it because I mean I only
live two miles from the local hospital
so I could go anywhere to get to occur I
would go anywhere to get uh to get the
treatment and that's what I've had to do
with me with my hips over the years and
obviously it's a shortage of stuff isn't
it you know there's no way that
um I can get uh an appointment with the
physio at the local hospital which are
employed by the um which are employed by
the uh NHS I mean this privacy go into
other areas so could Tony say to his
doctor look I'm not getting any Joy with
the hospital you've recommended me to
I've been on a waiting list of two years
can I go somewhere else price of choice
you can go you can choose to go
somewhere else of course you can and and
but what happens here you must see this
a lot you know a scan is a scan you know
it's a picture it it so what's the scan
for is it is it for a diagnosis yes it
is okay the dietary diet knows what well
if you've got a ruptured Achilles tendon
then you can't get about then clearly
that scan should take priority over a
scan that's just maybe checking I know
post-operative or you know it's it's a
it's a way of prioritizing the scans and
and and and it it exists Sarah Jane the
difficulty we've got is the NHS is so
busy at the at the moment the whole lot
seems to me to have imploded yeah okay
um we've been talking about waiting
times and we've also been talking a lot
here on Sky News about response times
ambulance response times as guys Becky
Johnson has been at the West Midlands
ambulance uh Service uh control center
uh for quite a few days now she's been
out and about with the teams as well
it's in Dudley and Becky what's
happening right there there right now we
keep hearing about these lengthening
response times talk to me about your
experience there in the control center
well they are still very busy of course
the pressures this winter have been
unprecedented we know that but
nationally we've heard today that the
waiting time at hospitals that
ambulances are having to wait before
they can hand over to a e has fallen
slightly on last month and that's what
we're seeing here at West Midlands
Ambulance Service I've got the latest
numbers last month in December the
longest a West Midlands Ambulance
Service ambulance wasted outside a
hospital was 32 hours and 57 minutes
quite extraordinary now this month the
longest is 11 hours 57 minutes so quite
an improvement now I'm told there are a
number of reasons for that firstly
they're seeing fewer cases of flu fewer
cases of covid and thankfully fewer
poorly children with strep a but they're
also doing things in the hospitals So
speaking to the paramedics here there
are now Advanced paramedic teams in some
of the busier a e departments across the
Midlands who have set up essentially in
in spaces within those a new units
working alongside Healthcare assistance
from the hospital so that ambulances can
hand over patients and these these
Advanced paramedics could be looking up
to around looking after around 12
patients at a time so they haven't quite
been admitted to hospital but at least
that ambulance can get then get back out
on the road because of course the worry
is that there are simply no ambulances
left to respond to category 1 calls
because they're all queuing outside
Hospitals now they're working all the
time here with the live data on the
walls and uh just a brief look at that
basically the more green there is the
better the more red there is the more
worrying you can see it's a bit of a
mixed picture today and I've got some
live data on this iPad here that's
telling me that at the moment the
longest wait an ambulance that's had
outside a hospital there's one ambulance
at Shrewsbury hospital that's been there
at two hours and 16 minutes another
ambulance the same hospital has been
there two hours and 10 minutes I mean
you know we're talking about things
getting better but better then really
bad isn't necessarily good and
ambulances should be handing patients
over within 15 minutes well looking at
these this data there are at least six
ambulances in the West Midlands that
have been waiting outside a e
departments for over an hour and are
still waiting there so still the
pressure is acute but perhaps just not
quite as bad as last month oh Becky
thank you Becky they're the snapshot of
what's going on inside the West Midlands
ambulance service call center you can
only imagine the pressure in that Center
when they're getting calls in and
they're trying to find an ambulance
that's free to get to those emergency
calls let's say from Carol in Sheffield
um she's got a good story for us her dad
broke his leg last week he was seen and
sorted including a trip in an ambulance
inside five hours Carol tell us more yes
exactly he a 90 bless him he fell on the
ice last Friday and it was about quarter
to ten in the morning mum called an
ambulance I wasn't there
um we don't quite remember how long the
owners took to come but no one no one
was standing around saying where's the
ambulance where's the ambulance at so
that's quarter to ten and about half
past two I got a call from the my senior
nurses in um recess and the accents
emerging department and that was so
that's half past two that's about five
and a half hours actually and they do
live a long way away they live 12 miles
away from us
about that on as well pardon me he
called me to say that Dad was
comfortable that he'd been treated for
his pain
had all his ex
seen obviously by the by the staff and
assessed he'd also been seen by the
accident emergency doctor a lovely lady
called Francis and she I spoke to her
again as well as this this verse and
they'd already made his diagnosis they
had a preliminary care plan intended at
that time and he didn't I didn't
actually go straight to the ward but it
wasn't very long until he went on
following that he added up that was um
Friday he had his operation on Sunday
yes I was an operation on Sunday and all
of his treatment has been absolutely
brilliant
but it all gone really Swimming by the
nurses on the ward have been fabulous
and I can't we can't praise them highly
enough and okay in the olden days five
and a half hours might have seemed like
a long time but let's be straight and
let's give them some some credit where
it's due to people who are still
managing to do a fabulous job because
they must get very demoralized when they
hear negative Stories the whole time
yeah 100 Carol people always want to
talk more about the bad things than they
do about the good things that's just the
nature of us as people isn't it but when
the NHS gets it right it is the best in
the world that's what Ellie was saying
earlier you know it is it is patchy it's
not horribly bad everywhere and it's not
super good everywhere there are
differences that's a good sometimes I
mean this this is this is classic the
operation was well within the nice
guidelines and and this is how it's
supposed to be done but it depends a lot
there are a lot of other factors I mean
first of all there's a demography of the
area where the hospital is does it have
a lot of very elderly frail people like
for example on the south coast there's
there's a higher incidence of elderly
people there so that makes a difference
it's where the hospital is and you often
find hospitals who are in coastal areas
find it very difficult to recruit and so
that's a problem if they don't have the
staff and so if there's a lot of
compounding factors that sit outside the
house hospital that impact what happens
inside the hospital and I just going
back to the report we we had about the
ambulance service the the the flu the
numbers for flu are starting to drop and
what we find with flu epidemics is there
a slow burn to start with and then they
compound and suddenly you're swamp with
people with the flu but when it burns
itself out they drop off a cliff so
hopefully we might be seeing the end of
the flu I mean I would say that that
story we heard I would say and obviously
I'm biased because I work in within the
NHS I would say that is more common than
people having I would say that is more
than normal people having a bad
experience so in my GP surgery we take
Google reviews and NHS choices reviews
and the majority of them are incredibly
positive both regarding the clinical
staff and the Administration staff and I
would say that as you say you know bad
news makes headlines and people talk
about sort of those issues much more but
but the majority because people working
with the NHS want to do a good job we in
the main are practicing gold standard
care within sort of the limited
resources that we have and I would say
that in the main
um we have we have good experiences no
one comes to work to keep people waiting
I'm just I'm just thinking back to Tony
we were speaking to from Preston who's
been waiting two years for that ankle
scan and the issue of fairness in terms
of we mentioned postcode Lottery how is
it fair that somebody in your area Ellie
gets five-star treatment great reviews
on Google for the hospital or the GB
surgery someone in Tony's area is having
a terrible time whether it's getting a
GP appointment having to go in an
ambulance and waiting for hours so again
that's all that's partly to do with what
Roy mentioned which is really
interesting actually about the
demography of Staff around the country
so I give you an example from my own
personal life so I work in a GP practice
which is really really good I'm a
patient in a GP practice which is really
not good actually and the person within
my family who's got a chronic condition
we've taken them out of that GP surgery
and put them in one half a mile down the
road registered there so we can get that
person very good care and yet the GP
surgery at the bottom of my road I don't
get good care now that's the same
demography it's the same area
and there is this terrible patchy
service it's all about shopping around
and doing your research
you know we do that in other areas of
life people don't change doctors you
know
all the evidence is if you look at the
numbers you know once you're with a GP
you stay and you just kind of put up
with it should it be that way it would
be a bit more proactive or not I mean
you know we should have one of these uh
uh websites where you can TripAdvisor
yeah TripAdvisor for health but I mean
well I think more tools are becoming
available for people to see how their GP
is doing whether it's league tables or
reviews all afternoon here on Sky News
we are taking your cause and giving you
the chance to share your views on the
state of the National Health Service
don't forget the numbers call today if
you want to have your say here with us
on the show 0208 167 double two double o
uh right let's get back to the calls
we're now going to talk about the
ongoing strike action within the Health
Service no end in sight to that more
dates announced for a February and March
let's talk to Vincent he is in
Birmingham he's a retired consultant uh
geriatrician and Vincent you don't
support the strikes tell us why
oh thank you very much
um let me say that it is not that I
don't support the strike and it's not
that I don't support the pay increase
for the hospital workers what I am
against is the timing
[Music]
um
I retired as a consultant geriatrician
in September 2021
while I was in service
there was we were always complaining
about inadequate remuneration for the
work we do
and at that time we were actually
considering going on strike and all that
um this time I am against the timing of
the strikes
because
the government we have now in place the
government of Rishi sunak is virtually a
new one last year we had three prime
ministers all in one go and he is here
so far he I'm not convinced that he is
doing wrong in fact I am satisfied with
his plan of action to revamp the NHS
and I think because they are new and
because they are just settling down we
should allow them time to settle before
we begin to go on strike because if you
do know what people are going to be
saying at home some people at home are
going to be saying look you know
Richie's soon act might be new but the
conservatives aren't you they've been in
power for over a decade and we've had
prime minister after prime minister uh
promising to to boost the NHS to invest
in the NHS to bring it up to where it
was
um but in the last you know 10 to 12
years the NHS has deteriorated so the
government isn't new it might be a new
prime minister but it's the same
government
yeah I agree I do agree but he appears
to have a new sense and a new way of
doing things
um from what he has outlined I I still
think that we should give him maybe one
year two years to see how he does
um do you think he should talk to the
National Health Service workers who are
striking because what we're hearing from
um those on the picket lines and I know
you don't just you don't agree with
these strikes necessarily the timing of
them but what we're hearing from those
on the picket lines is that the
government won't even engage with them
they won't even talk to them about their
demands whether well not their demands
their ass whether it be about pay or
conditions they're not engaging I think
Rishi sunak if he is shiny and new and
getting to grips with it he should sit
down and talk to them actively engage
with them about pay
yes I am not spokesperson
um what I understand Rishi sunak did was
to set up a peer review committee that
made some recommendations all of which
he accepted
um every one of us we all adults every
one of us knows that this government as
it is now doesn't have much money the
nursing staff started by requesting a
pay increase of 19 percent
um he can't I don't think my knowledge
I'm not an economist but I don't think
he can give them that and give the
ambulance drivers and give the Border
agency workers and everybody that will
lead to severe inflation in this country
and we'll know what that will amount you
that is what I'm saying yes I agree he
should talk to anybody who has a reason
for wanting to go on strike he shouldn't
avoid them he should talk to every
individual that is part of his job
description I'm sure
um but in terms of every one of all
everybody expecting the money they are
demanding in this current circumstance I
I don't think I think it's a very hard
ask yeah that's my impression I get it
Vincent if you give in to one you have
to give in to all like you said so many
people on strike at the moment we're
only talking about the NHS today you've
got Railway workers and you know
teachers considering going on strike and
gosh the environment agency there are so
many people going on strike at the
moment I completely take your point give
in to one you have to give in to them
all let's talk to Gavin from Kent and
Gavin had a stroke and had an amazing
experience within the NHS and believes
that the NHS staff should be paid more
Gathering first of all how are you talk
to you about your experience that's too
bad thank you funny enough my videos
just left my house
what was that sorry I said funny enough
the physio has just left my home about
10 minutes we caught you at the right
time
yeah talk to me about the experience you
had in hospital then what why are you
such a big fan of treatment
up the West End on the night out for our
anniversary our wedding anniversary all
of a sudden I started feeling ill when I
went over like a tree and um she
realized I was having a stroke and she
phoned an ambulance I was there in like
three minutes within 20 minutes I was
having um I was having Care Medical Care
fortunately enough where's right on top
of the hospital within half an hour I
was having proper care so I had an acute
stroke but
um it saved my life and then I can't I
can't say the word but I I had to do a
cranioscopy which means they've took off
me skull off my head
um
um so they've done that
I don't know who's ringing me in now
and I mean Gavin you know you said it
yourself you owe the NHS your life so
for you money money is No Object talk to
me about some of the the staff that that
you met and how they looked after I've
been in five hospitals
yes five in total and I think Richie
soon actually going to pack an overnight
bag and going in a cute stroke unit and
watch how many jobs do nurses have to do
in an hour
let's see it with his own eyes
personally or one of the MPS go in there
and take a bed for the night and go and
have a look
and go and live it a little bit
only 25 of nursing shifts are fully
staffed
of nursing so when they're working on a
tremendous pressure
I mean the nurses that I see are running
around doing five jobs at a time
and like I said I'll thank I'll thank
them all because I think they've been
absolutely brilliant in NHS personally
that's my experience and I think we
should find the money and give them the
money
yeah I mean Gavin you're not alone you
do hear from so many people who have had
whether it's life-saving treatment or
you know
um bringing you life into the world in a
maternity unit you know people have so
many positive stories about the NHS I've
got nothing but good to say personally
yeah yeah no I I I can fully understand
why government for me
okay well let's get a sense now of the
pressure on NHS staff and the reason
that they have launched uh this
industrial action uh Paul Turner
paramedic for the Northwest Ambulance
Service he's also a deputy Branch
Secretary at the GMB Union
um Paul that's just one of the many
positive
um stories we're getting here at Sky
News Today on our your say program uh
people value the NHS and you know a lot
of people say he can't put a price on
you know saving lives but actually you
can when it comes to paying staff
properly and enabling them to work in
better conditions all around the NHS the
staffing needs investment that's why
you're striking
yeah so the strikes are based on two
elements the first element is about the
public safety and the second part is
about the 10 years of austerity faced by
NHS workers
um and I appreciate we are not the only
ones on strike but I can only talk about
the NHS because that's what I work for
that's what I'm interested in and you
know we we miss other very important
Services out there that are not eligible
for strike but again from this
government we're rewarded pretty much
nothing as a pay rise because gas
electric mortgage rates rent rates they
all go up but our wages never match
inflation now I'm not saying we deserve
an inflation busting pair eyes but it
needs to at least match
um inflation because of the 10-year
austerity that we've experienced you
know I listened to Vincent the first
gentleman that was on
um and I I you know
I don't agree with what he's saying
there's no right time to take a strike
nobody in the NHS ever wants to go on
stride we're here to look after the
patients that we serve but every single
day when we're trying to do that because
of the underfunding and the lack of
resources we've got We are failing every
single day and now it's come to a point
where enough is enough and NHS staff
can't carry the burden any longer people
are waiting hours and hours for
ambulances which is not acceptable
there's often when I'm at work my
colleagues are at work right across the
UK where we're hearing our radios
pinging saying there's category one
emergency is outstanding whilst we're
stood outside corridors or in a
completely different area to where we
should be it's not unusual for me to
travel an hour an hour and a half to an
incident on blue lights and Sirens to
get to someone who needs us because
there's no resources available in that
area and that's because of the amount of
under-resourcing that we're facing
you know it's really stressful at the
moment in the NHS you know you don't get
a break from it your 12 hour shift or
your eight hour shift can turn into 14
15 hours easily
um you're lucky if you get anything to
eat or drink during your shift because
you stood on corridors
um and that poor patient when you've
gone home is still sat potentially on
that Corridor or in your cold ambulance
um and you come back into following
shift and the patient's still there
because they've not moved that is not
acceptable at all moving forward
I hear people saying there's no money
for you know pay Rises things like that
but we managed to find money for MP
expenses for instance they claim more in
expenses that the 999 callers get paid
working for the NHS taking those 999
calls
um it's outrageous that we're carrying
on in in the way we are
and now we are struggling to recruit
into those areas
um because other
service providers other jobs are paying
more than what you can working for the
NHS which fair play to them because
they're looking after their workers and
people could say well leave the job if
you don't want to do it go work there
but then who's going to do the job that
I that I do and one of the other things
that really frustrates people is how
degrading it is being called an
ambulance driver
um I'm a highly educated uh Medical
Professional I've done three years at
University to obtain a degree like all
of my colleagues have and even our
EMTs and dispatchers and call takers and
everybody else across the NHS you now
need to have minimum qualifications to
be to be eligible for those roles so to
be called ambulance drivers I I think
it's a bit of a kick it kick in the
teeth and that's coming directly from
the government
yeah Paul I can sense the frustration in
your voice you know you're living and
breathing this and you know a phrase
that I heard earlier this week you know
people aren't dying because NHS Workers
are striking and issues Workers are
striking because people are dying is
what you're talking about yeah that's
correct a recent GMB survey our members
believe that patients are now dying
because of the delays that's not me
saying that that's you know 20
000 GMB members across the ambulance
service saying that you know we are
facing this every single day and you
know I don't want to be on strike every
Dam on strike I lose pay and write me so
because I'm not providing that service
um however I will never get that money
back and then rightly so I won't get
that money back but I'm doing it because
otherwise I attention won't happen
because it won't be here we cannot get
staff we are massively underfunded and
massively under-resourced and I'm not
going to get on to how badly we're
treated through the covid pandemic we
didn't even have suitable PPE which
again we're Wasted millions and millions
of pounds a year storing it out of date
in a warehouse
you have to remind yourself why you
still do this job why do you still do it
I do the job because I love helping
patients there's nothing better than
saving someone's life you know
delivering a child you know preventing
that potential death when you get there
there's nothing more rewarding rewarding
than that and that side of the job I
absolutely love and that's why I
continue to do it but the politics
behind it it's just it we've had enough
I cannot stress it our members have had
enough I've had enough people are
leaving in droves we cannot recruit
because you can work elsewhere and get
more money or the equivalent for less
stress it's all the stress that you take
home with you you go home after 12 14 15
hours knowing that that patient's still
going to be sat there in the morning
it's just not fair and it's not right
and and I again listen to Vincent about
giving rushy Sue Knack a chance no we've
added Tory government now for too long
we need a change not very political to
be fair don't really not really
interested who gets there but we need to
have a change we need somebody in power
that actually cares about the public
um Paul thank you stay with us for just
a moment um a really impassioned uh
conversation there with Paul we could
just feel your passion for the NHS
service and your frustration about what
you're going through she says you
studied for three years do this job to
save people's lives and you're not able
to do your job properly and let's speak
to Jason in Newcastle now um Jason was
in a motorbike accident and spent five
months in an NHS hospital and Jason what
was your experience in that hospital
because because what I can see from the
notes my producer has given me you feel
like a lot of money and time is wasted
in hospitals
I would have to agree with you then so
um
like I said I was there for just over
five months in in hospital and I was
between two hospitals so I was initially
airlifted to a Scottish hospital
um where they carried out the surgery
and things like that today and and then
I was transferred to an English hospital
to be repatriating course at the home
now the first thing that
comes to mind anywhere is the fact that
it was cheaper to use a private
ambulance than what it was to use an NHS
ambulance which I thought was staggering
um so that was that was that was out um
saw Street Rio now when I was part of
in the English Hospital the
hospital I would say a lot of wasted
money now I'm from a timber frame
background in the private sector where
things were basically production line
and you know you had to work for what
you had to get now in the NHS that I'm
led to believe anywhere from from stuff
when I was when I was in hospital that
when you take a day off from work you
actually paid for the deal from work and
you just don't proceed a shift
enhancements whereas in a regular job
you would lose your first three days and
things like that and so there will be a
waste of money for me anyway so you'll
be paid everything by your shift
enhancement for going to go into work
but you don't absolutely turn up
um there was World managers and things
like that which would take and from what
I believe anyway from my research so
they were like grade seven or grade band
seven or band aids
um 43 000 pounds a year plus
um walking round and I don't know what
the situation was people that were
basically tearing pennies off using PBE
and things like that to walk around
asking patients how they were doing then
tearing it off again and putting it in
the bin and then carrying on walking
around I was thinking myself right well
I don't understand what your purpose is
exactly within the hospital and so I
don't see why you'll be paying 43 000
pounds a year for you to be doing what
you're doing I don't really understand
with that
um I ended up having a few meetings with
the board manager on on my particular
Ward
um about how staff were behaving
um how for instance there would be four
sisters on a ward uh two nurses and say
for instance three carers
um to look after the positions now while
my water wasn't a particularly busy Ward
and so I can't speak for the for the
whole hospital I've got no doubt that in
other Awards uh things are really busy
like when our previous gender members
seeing about the stroke award I've got
no doubt that it's a it's a really busy
Ward but on the ward that I was on you
couldn't get staff for loving the money
through Monday or Friday but yet when it
came to a weekend when there was
enhancements or time and a half rates of
paying double times for a Sunday you
couldn't get moved for nurses
um on the ward you know so I've got the
the thing to myself but there's another
amount of money that doesn't need to be
spent
um
okay Jason well what you're talking
about is accountability and you did the
right thing you asked questions you
asked to speak to the ward manager about
what you were seeing and that's probably
a good example to set in terms of asking
questions whether it's about your care
or the environment you're in within the
NHS let's quickly speak to Anthony from
Chessington who's been hanging on um
Anthony
um I'm really sorry to hear he had a
seizure two weeks ago and and your
ambulance weight went from two to nine
hours so you went back to bed and woke
up with concerns
over a cardiac arrest what happened
basically what happened is I had a
seizure and
um I was in the hallway and I had a
seizure in the hallway and my my wife
had to call for the ambulance and then
basically he's waiting for quite a while
for the ambulance to come out and um
when they came out after quite a while
um they came and did tests on me and
said yes basically
um your
um symptoms of having a heart attack
and they took me to hospital and I was
still waiting in the ambulance for quite
a while because the lift on the back of
the ambulance stopped working and I was
stuck in the ambulance for quite a while
as well
and
um when
um the people came and said we won't we
can't take you out of the bed in case
you do have a cardiac arrest
um you're gonna have to wait in the
ambulance and then when I got into the
hospital I was waiting for five hours
before even anybody come and did any
checks on me anything basically
Anthony it must have been an extremely
extremely worrying time for you and your
family I'm just going to bring in
um Paul Turner as well um from the
Northwest Ambulance Service a paramedic
A GMB Union Deputy Branch Secretary I
mean Paul these stories will not be
unfamiliar to you you know you
experience them day in day out and I
appreciate you staying with us because I
know you've got to go and do the school
run because you know you work and you
have a family talk to me about how all
of this is affecting you personally
because you know we talk about pay and
conditions this is your work life but
you know how much is it affecting your
your day-to-day life your personal life
it's very difficult it affects all of my
colleagues exactly the same you know we
you can't really arrange anything after
work so if you you know due to finish at
seven o'clock in the evening and you've
got to get your children you know our
partners might work night shifts because
we're on days here you're working
opposite you you can't guarantee you're
going to be home at seven o'clock
because you might then be stood out in
the hospital for another four or five
hours
um so it becomes a lot of stressful
stressfulness that shouldn't really be
there
um listening to those poor individuals
there that have experienced such bad
Care by the NHS not the staff but
because of the under-resourcing it is
just not acceptable it really isn't and
you know I I hand on heart tell you now
none of the NHS staff want to be on
strike we really don't we want the
government to get around the table give
us a plan of how the NHS is going to
look in two or five years time and also
talk about pay we need to understand
what the government are going to do
moving forward it cannot carry on like
this and I fundamentally believe that we
are privatizing the NHS through the back
door I know every single day we put out
private ambulances every day responding
to our calls because we don't have
enough staff we don't have enough people
there so they have to bring in private
providers Paul we have to leave it there
and you have to go thank you so much for
talking to us about your experiences